Prince I I met in a really weird way in
Los Angeles and he came over to talk to
me he sat down next to me where it was
at a dinner and he sat down next to me
and he goes uh I moved to LA to be
around people who are in it and you're
in it and I was so nervous I was like
yeah I know totally what you mean yeah
I'm in it uh and then I just went I
could not stop talking I every little
piece of knowledge I knew about Prince
just started pouring out of my mouth I
was like oh I just watched a documentary
about Jehovah's Witnesses did you know
that uh you know did you know that
Jehovah's Witnesses there were
Innovations in bloodless surgery because
of Jehovah's Witnesses and he was like
yes yes I know I knew and then for years
he would invite me to watch see him play
at it he said he like I throw parties
you should come I was like I would
totally come to Prince's house and uh I
would get messages every now and then
like oh Chris is having a party tomorrow
can you come I'd be like I'm in New York
I can't like I don't I don't have a
plane I can't just go like I work
musicians have no concept of what the
real world is they're so at one thing I
know about musicians they don't know
from work they don't you know they don't
have concept that you have to go to work
I feel like such a nerd saying every
time like I actually I have a show at
night I can't just I can't miss it for a
party and then finally he played in a
room at the Gansevoort Hotel one time
and invited me and I went and it was
incredible I was like I don't know 30
people or something in this room
watching Prince play and he's playing
and it's like I don't know he didn't go
on to like 1am or something and I was
working the next day and I'm exhausted
but I was so excited to see him and
right before he went on like one of his
people came over to me and said Prince
would like you to stay afterward uh
because he'd like to talk to you about
the financial crisis this was like in
2008 and first of all I know nothing
about the financial crisis I'm the last
person to like give Financial advice so
I was like uh okay yeah sure and it got
he kept playing and playing and it was
like 2 A.M then and like 2 30 and I was
like I gotta get out of here I finally
had to leave and I had to go to his
person be like I I have to work at like
6 a.m tomorrow I I can't stay to talk
about the financial crisis
foreign